when chat gbd first came out I I know
that the people who made it and I said
did you know it was going to work and
they said no none of us knew it was
going to work if you looked at its
predecessors they didn't work well and
and suddenly chat gbt started working
you know what chat gbt is doing is it's
taking a trillion words basically from
the web from a bunch of books things
like that and it's saying given that I
was started with this the the words the
best thing about AI is its ability to
given what I saw on the web what's the
next word likely to be
that's it that's its basic strategy and
it just keeps doing that word by word
and it's kind of remarkable U nowadays
these things have well it used to be
4,000 it's now more than that uh window
of words that it pays attention to it's
generating one word at a time but yet it
manages to maintain sort of coherence um
by having a large window of of words
that it can look back to